okay for people joining this
live stream we are looking at some
language completeness and consistency
issues
for i think for version 12.3 of
language which is quite imminent oh yeah
these will say 12.3 oh
first two do all right first one
geometric query
what is geometric query i'm sure i've
seen this before but i don't and and how
does it relate
to okay all right let's take a look here
oh i was muted which is why you were
ignoring me yes
well the first note addresses how it's
or is it the second note now
um uh yes
uh i see i see i see i see okay
oh boy i don't know about this name you
know look
query is used in the data set framework
for
a symbolic query
i don't like this name maybe i suggested
it last time
uh you did not suggest it but you ran
with it i believe it was suggested
by somebody on the live stream and then
you
you really liked it last time so i know
but i'm i've
this is what you know you kind of you
sleep on it for a week or something
and um yeah i mean if it's just a matter
of renaming it i mean i don't think the
function
i don't think you disagree with the
functionality no i don't disagree with
the functionality
okay so there is an assertion geometric
assertion
and there's a kind of geometric test or
something
right yes so yeah i would be okay with
geometric tests because that's really
what it does
or geometric condition that sounds a bit
funny but no
i think geometric condition again sounds
like it might be symbolic
let's take a look at what it would look
like geometric test
okay so let's say for example tangent
okay so geometric test object let's just
write it out just for fun
okay okay geometric
test of you know
disc 0 0
disk 1 1
tangent and let's just see what it would
look like
okay so geometric test okay
so geometric query
just to be clear this won't work because
disks uh
um circles would work
right why won't it work for disks
because
circles are are have dimension too
and so what why can't they be tangent i
i don't see why those regions can't be
tangent
why aren't those tangent because they're
oh they're not you want that one of them
to be at like
a 2-0 right because they have radius one
so their centers
are two apart boy am i clueless
i was expecting it to be true too so you
weren't the only one
okay um
okay
so let's see
so geometric assertion
asserts this fact for symbolic such
things
correct geometric test
is the non-symbolic version of geometric
assertion
so the set of first arguments to
geometric assertion is disjoint from the
set of first arguments to geometric
blank whatever this is is that correct
because in the case of geometric
assertion they always contain symbolic
things
um otherwise they're asserting a
tautology well so
so uh yes and no so
geometric only geometric assertion will
allow
like a symbol a to represent a whole
point
but if you put in
um point zero i see i see i see so
you're saying if this was circle blah
radius r and this said two r
and that said r then i'd still get
shuffle waffle the heck is that
uh we're working on simplifying the uh
the uh
output what would happen if i said
result does resolve simplify that
right it just in some cases
resolve will basically hang so it's
kind of um okay and that is
not my i mean honestly that is
not the finest hour of okay
okay fine that's nice if i just said
that just out of curiosity and this is
probably an adam question
um oh yeah beautiful well
yeah okay yeah
okay so notably
geometric test see notably this doesn't
just
return true or false right right right
so what other things do we have in this
general space
of things that um
reach remember co-linear i think
i think a linear is one of the ones that
represents but what i'm asking is things
things where there is a condition
and we return you know where you ask
something and you're either told oh i
see you you're answering this region
member is an example one where
it gives you back the conditions under
which it's true it's correct
that's why it's not each member queue
yeah right so like co-linear points q
will give you false whenever there's
a symbol but region member will give you
the conditions on x and y
um that's it i mean i know convex
polygon q does that i thought collinear
points
would uh give you conditions oh maybe
linear points does
i'm pretty sure collinear points gives
you condition oh because it's not a q
it's just co-linear points right at the
point right
yeah so we have convex polygon q which
only works for
polygons with no symbols in them and
it's a q function returns
true or false but then we have collinear
points with no q
which gives conditions
okay okay so this
this is the general version of this
yes
right so so for for things i mean
you know i right so for example
the polygons i mean polygons are sort of
a special case right because
our polygons can be sort of you know
polygons with holes and other sort of
special things that don't really fit
into the
euclidean framework right um
but i think for most of these things
where we have a dedicated function this
is yes this and the property it'll
right so for we have like collinear is
one of the properties right so you could
in fact we have a properties and
relations example showing that you know
collinear points and
geometric query with collinear give
give you know the same answer yeah okay
all right so the question here is
geometric assertion asserts it
i i kind of think geometric test is the
least crazy of these
okay i mean what do other people think
you know
in um
you're probably going to ruin the day of
the guy who came up with geometric query
on the live stream but
geometric testing well thank you for
i just want to say thank you for the
suggestion
um he's getting another 15 minutes of
fame
oh no the important thing is we're
talking about him
uh-huh or them
hard to define
or it's a bot very smart bot
and then what do you what is the pronoun
for a bot
i guess it's it yes yeah but now it's it
until the ais really rise up and and
assert their rights
well there was that whole movie her
which
yes
and it was about a clown although the
clown was not named it
interesting okay the uh
all right so um
geometric test
it's the best i can come up with are we
leaving it experimental for this version
yes yes all right
okay otherwise it seems as i mean it's
interesting the first word here is tests
mm-hmm
i mean geometric property test but i
think it's silly
geometric test is as reasonable as
anything here
okay yeah
i'll just say i'll make it so okay
good ethan is talking about condition
functions that end in c we we did talk
about that we kind of decided not to
pull the trigger on that
um
okay the big things interface
okay so what we're looking at here
so these have been reviewed by these are
mockups that have been reviewed by
jeremy
and have not yet been implemented okay i
just want to
sandra is commenting on our live stream
that there are a bunch of functions that
end and start
oh boy
right so those are mostly well obviously
same test is an option but i'll
write a lot of these function and so is
zero test
but a lot of these are
our statistical tests
which right now
return what
okay so this is so if i say kuiper test
i think it returns like this whole
object that you can query
thing you know various statistical
properties of
a number i guess right because
right that's how right house is the
horsebox
right you have the chi-squared test and
the
no i understand that this is some
probability then
well it's the number spit out by the
test and then you
have to interpret that number
right just like in you know your
standard error analysis right you have
the reduced chi
squared which is you know a number
and then you have to go and look up in
the table or calculate the probability
that that was random chance based on
that number
let's say this is not the most lovely
documentation because it's
tests whether i would expect to be true
or false
devendra were you involved in in these
pages or was this sort of
after you separated from the
stats folk yeah and by the way also i
would like to point out this is not how
we should be doing this
there's this data equals things just
wrong wrong wrong
should just be kuiper test of this
variant thing
okay this is really horrible in terms of
documentation
let's probably go there to andy ross i
mean there's a lot of oh this is from
there
i'm just thinking i'm thinking that
let's say then which i think if it's
around version eight version nine that's
probably him
i didn't do the data thing mostly okay
all right anyway so can we feed this
back to folks
devon i think that's for you yeah this
really isn't isn't the right way to do
it 11 years later
i mean no it's fine what the function
returns is fine i just think the
documentation is kind of
badly worded okay big things interface
all right so walk me through what we're
roughly looking at here
right so when you have a lara so the
first
part of this is when you have a summary
box
right and we have sort of right we have
this
the the the expression itself is small
and then you don't get anything you just
get the summary box
right there because it contains
everything because it contains
everything
um let me make a comment about that case
maybe in that case
when you plus when you open the plus
there should be an element at the end
that says
uh you know data stored in notebook or
something
just to give confirmation that it really
is there
[Music]
so it would return to itself but that
message updates right the message that
says data not notebook that has to
change
so well it goes away once you've stored
it
oh right so
okay so here it could say elements and
then it could say
um
i don't know how it wants to work it's
stored
data included in object and brands or
something
don't we have a encoding that isn't that
implied with most of these objects
yeah fine you're right it is it is the
default
okay fine all right okay so now right so
if you change that to you know 10 to the
fifth there so we have something just so
you can compare
the what's currently there it's just an
updated design from what we've got
currently i don't know are there new
features as well
there's also new features so right now
you just have that one option
and when you click on it it gets stored
and
the ribbon goes away so now we're giving
you two other choices which are
to store it in the cloud or in a local
object
and then there's this other case where
for very large
um expressions because we don't want to
crash the front end
we disable right now you can't do
anything with those it just says
can't store object in notebook but
the idea is we gray out do you store a
notebook but let you still
store in local object or in the cloud
although if it's too large to start in
the notebook well if you have a really
good internet connection maybe you want
to store it in the cloud but
on some level if it's too big to turn
the notebook it probably doesn't want to
be in the cloud
can i suggest that we take out these we
just say embedded line and notebook
store in local object store in cloud
i don't think the va et cetera is useful
where's the look take out the word v
take out the word a take out the word
this
ah those determiners are useful
yes that i i i i have no object
no you know shorter shorter text as long
as it's clear is always to be preferred
over longer text
now my only question is the blue for
store now i mean you've made it look
appropriate billy by showing it in a
case where this is blue but it won't
necessarily be blue
do you understand what i'm saying i mean
is i is that icon usually in a blue
palette
well you have some similar things for
audio uh it goes blue
um but okay but do you know what the
we've avoided red because it's it's more
of a urgency or error state so
so blue's a standard action and it's
hyper link like too so
it looks clickable
looks weird to me right i mean i i mean
certainly i
so i absolutely have no problem with
going blue on hover in fact i think
we're doing that in multiple places
whether it needs color
um i'm not sure it needs color it could
just be black
or all right now we have a blue
arrow and i think a gray notebook
so it's more subtle but but a bit of
color is nice i think
yeah i mean this red one i think the red
yeah yeah but the blue version of that
is pretty nice
what other color palette could we use
here anything else we have going for us
like an orange or something orange we
use orange for ribbons
for for um attached cells
we could use that and i tend to think of
orange as sort of more entity-ish
so yes
what else is this like well we're
probably going to see a bunch of other
things so blue is the issue here
in terms of of this why are these
separated buttons why is this not
not just like a um a standard um
you know menu is so that you can
directly to save a click
right so i mean instead of going from
one click to three clicks
we're going from one clicks to two
clicks
i see um i mean
right we did have the the ma and what's
currently in the prototype build
um which was an earlier iteration
um i think has a menu button
and and then you you know click ok
and it was you know our discussion last
time suggested that
uh well no this is this version has just
not been graphically designed
uh okay right
but we do have action menus that look
like a menu but you
choose the item one click and it takes
action
yeah that's what a standard menu does
right so it wouldn't take more clicks we
could make it
they don't have to look like buttons
they'd need a hover effect
like a row hover effect and it's like
it's just like something like a menu
yeah
right right so so we have a couple of
alternatives which may be
more in that thing i think that's what
should be done i think it's just too
much
too much fussiness to have separate
buttons for these
and then this would be you know at the
bottom as something
that doesn't you know those are just
like like um
menu items okay
this blue is not making it for me it
bothers me
all right well stephen can you first
just look at the alternates and
we might also want to look at the at the
output size limiter
right yeah sure fine is this wait a
minute
how's it touched so why is this is this
an alternative what is this
uh oh it i guess the difference is the
sort of the
right the alignment and how the
right where the icon is where the
you know and then the behavior is it
right it drops down from the left side
rather than
i think originally billy wanted
everything to line up but i think it's
not possible given how it's implemented
to keep everything aligned
so we we went with this first option
okay
right so that's a more menu-ish sort of
well it's better we should just do it
this way
no on however that's wrong you should do
the the standard um
uh conversion should be blue or
something
or or just ideally inherited from the
system
if we can do that look
what about putting this icon at the end
store now you're storing
that works either way i wanted it
connected to store now not
date and no fine yeah okay my preference
here with these
i think this is overly fussy i think
that
the whole thing i think it should be
data not a notebook and i think that
that kind of blue is probably okay store
now and there's an icon there
okay it's just one line like this
and then it on hover produces this menu
you go select the thing and you're happy
people
that's what i think okay now
are are you suggesting just to blow us
the foreground or also the white
background
it feels a bit the white's a bit
disconnected
yeah that's how i'm feeling yeah yeah it
should still have some gray
but also do these ever get really wide
the the summary boxes they can get wide
especially in an open state
[Music]
but uh what would this do and what does
this do in the open state
right so something like sparse array is
uh do something
like uh okay so this can go down like
that this gets pushed down to the bottom
like that
right yeah and we'd stay left aligned
okay
yeah okay what's the other case
uh well something like links bracket
bracket will probably produce some
large
you know some wider guys but i don't
know that any of them
yeah i think that's right none of them
have the little badge
so yeah but if it was badged
i think you have to match the gray here
because otherwise it's going to look
stupid
so it's just a segmented piece at the
bottom
and then it's distinguished by having
presumably some
darker blue type color could you try and
mock that billy
okay including get one which is
you know both the non-wide and the extra
wide okay because in the extra wide
there's gonna be a lot of white space or
gray space here
what about menu alignment are you okay
with aligning with store now or are you
thinking given it's all blue now it
aligns with the
i think it should
um
it be possible to change how it's stored
after you've selected one of the things
boy that's an interesting question you
know it probably should be
it probably should be that should
probably be something that when you hit
the plus
it should probably allow that as at the
end
to say what state is go ahead yeah
i don't i mean i i i disagree i
uh it's that that doesn't really
uh feel like something i've wanted and
right what's the
right i mean there are certain
well you haven't had these capabilities
before you're storing local objects and
storing cloud
imagine it's embedded and then the
notebook becomes too big
and you're not sure what to do
or you know you click store in local
object and
you can you know a minute later like no
i should have done that in cloud for
whatever reason oh because i'm going to
send it to somebody else
right i do also think that there should
probably be an information button down
at the
expression size level down there and i
and that should go to some page that's a
workflow page
that talks about what these options are
that make sense because it's not
self-evident you can't email
somebody the one after you've stored in
a local object you're toast
at that point i'm making sense
right um it's also a question when you
store it in the cloud
you are by default storing in something
with your default uh
umass effectively so your default
permission structure
which doesn't allow other people to get
access to it
[Music]
right so you you're going to email this
notebook to somebody
does it have its assets accessible to
them
right so so the the design right now is
that there is
right it shows the cloud object right so
you can manipulate it but i don't think
it's
changes right i think it is using the
default umass
[Music]
i think there's a little bit more to
this i think that in the in a
um in a perfect world the notebook
toolbar would know whether there were
these things in this notebook
so that you could bank switch it and say
take all these assets and move them to
public cloud
see what i'm saying
right even you know when you're about to
do the mailing of the notebook if you if
you use our mailing system
say you know would you like this would
you like these assets move to the cloud
so that people can pick them up
i think we're going to need that i mean
this is obviously fine for this version
but let's
and again i like brett's suggestion that
if you buy
his point well well if you start in line
right this whole thing disappears and i
i no that's good and we shouldn't we
shouldn't change that
i mean i think once you start anywhere
you know the stripe at the bottom goes
away yeah obviously but it's question
one no no the stripe does not go away
when you store it in a cloud object or a
local object
uh i mean it's a different stripe but
the stripe does not disappear
i see because that that is a
fundamentally
different object right
it's yes it's a get it's an
import or get or whatever of or
okay but so here's the question let's
say you stored it as a
embedded in the notebook and the
notebook is getting very very big
okay what do you do
so it is similar to you know the
very old 35 year old you know delete all
output menu item
or make outputs bitmaps or so or
something
you know it's again it's a thing go
through and push these assets
to the cloud
yes that that that's possible
um what do we i
yeah manually embedded couldn't we just
leave the stripe there
and say it's embedded and have a file
size or something
it's it's an edge case anyway
so what i mean but jeremy well
because normally it disappears because
it's usually not there but in this case
it's there because it's a big file size
no i wouldn't worry about it i wouldn't
worry about it i think that i think that
would allow you to
send it to the cloud right you can't
send it to the cloud because it's not
there
but you it could be there all right but
right but if you want to send it
to the cloud right you can just do slash
you know
cloud put right the whole point is if
it's in the notebook you can
treat it just like anything else that's
in the notebook no no no
jeremy's making a different point my
suggestion for the solution is
as soon as you embed it locally the
stripe goes away
but if you press plus the bottom
of the actual properties that you see
within press plus
is a copy of the stripe okay
that's my suggestion i it at the very
least has a file size there which is
pretty useful
if it's big yeah right but but
right i mean those guys aren't
distinguishable from guys which never
had the stripe
right which means everything will now
have the stripe
no i would be perfectly happy to have a
cut off
and if it's tiny there's no reason to
have the stripe
look it's the same cutoff if it ever had
the stripe
leave the stripe but put it underneath
the plus if you told it to embed
that's my suggestion
i just don't see how that's
implementable right i mean it's
it's right why because because
right once you embed it it's it's right
it's it's
you know the box structure is no
different from something which never had
the strike
i see
i see okay well then we're toast on that
we
there's nothing we can do with that so
then then the best we can do is in the
notebook toolbar we can say go hunt and
hunt down
any summary box that's bigger than such
and such
and go you know process it basically
yes okay fine that's what we have to do
okay and if it was stored non-locally
not in the notebook then it will
maintain this the visible stripe
right okay okay i would like to make one
suggestion here that maybe there should
be two different store and cloud um
next door privately storing cloud print
privately
storing cloud prem publicly
uh uh in principle i have no objection
to that
uh i just you don't have to do it today
but i think
i think it'd be useful um
yeah i mean i think we need some input
from yon or joel or somebody about how
exactly we would want to do that
um so okay fine but okay don't forget
the
the i down at the bottom under
expression size that gives you workflows
that explain what's going on in these
cases okay sense
okay and
we have a picture here from
i think i missed that eye part what i
just do here crazy crazy
um
okay here it goes
i'm good with all this i think this
looks nice i i still this blue still
bothers me
it's not actually yeah you could go
much darker on the blue color okay i did
actually try changing it
i'll change it even darker and maybe
maybe not have blue for data
not notebook well i i mean i think
i mean we want it to be a little bit
loud right i mean we want people to know
that
the data's not there right now now here
do we really want this or do we want it
to go all the way across
i think i think that's what we already
do on data set
that right this thing here i wasn't sure
if i should include that example or not
but yeah i i looked real quick it's on
the right hand
uh side though because i think there are
some hover things that appear on the
lower left side
for me if we had a choice i'd make it
match with it just looks weird to hang
down like that
but if we're not but still but still be
left aligned
but still left aligned yeah i'm not sure
where else you put it
okay okay can
billy try some more colors here if you
could okay
break magenta
oh yeah that'll not generate any all
caps emails ever
okay all right let's go down here um
right so the output size which i'm i'm
i'm not sure i totally understand all of
these
suggestions but we can you can certainly
talk them through
so i think the the ask was to include
icons next to
each of the options
and what some of this is doing is trying
to make a
lower width option because even right
now
without the icons under number one
there's a note
like the third item down currently
intersects the
show suggestion bar icon so that's how
it is now so with the icons it makes it
even
wider um but i was also trying to figure
out what some of this
maybe responsive behavior would be uh so
that's kind of what's going on in this
first section
um and then in the next section is the
trying to
figure out how to reduce the width so
there's no
we don't bump into this all right
so
this is going from blue to gray for the
output size limiter
is that right i
think so yeah i mean the output size
limiter as it is today
looks like this
oh it's been changed in this version
i think i have a master well i i have a
um
previous version here
right the uh although the whole color
scheme is more bluish
it was for it was from your from your
blue
era or or blue face what is it that the
artist yeah yeah blue face blue period
your blue period exactly
okay
right and you're like i don't object to
the blue background here i just object
to these that look totally different
from everything else we have
okay well last time you spoke you you
said
that we should color match the the these
two large
things i kind of think we should yes so
is that the shade of blue to use for
the thing that we were just discussing
no because this well i don't know
whether the blue matches down here or
not
no i mean the the link previous topic
yeah it's a better blue than the one we
had but i don't know
i just this one's pretty vibrant
saturated okay so look i don't know
art people figure this out come on we
can we can
i i don't know i mean i think here
maybe it's just because you know my
screen is shrinking your monitor a bit
but i have to say that
i i find those buttons pretty hard to
read
and yeah um very gray
what is it what was the change trying to
match to
to the summary boxes right so since we
were expanding the interface on the
summary boxes there was the thought that
we should
match the colors okay let's just talk
about what happens here so
if you got a two big output it's
the main event summary boxes there could
be
200 of them in a list and blah blah blah
i don't think you can get that here this
is the main event this is spanning the
whole
output line correct
in other words if i take this right
that is one big blob and i say percent
29 comma percent 29
i'm gonna get one blob
right so this is the thing
that unlike a summary box is a
you know this is all of your output guys
yes exactly now of course you may have a
narrow notebook or a large font size
so sure but i'm kind of thinking maybe
the way to do this is something
where there's heavier things above and
below to kind of make it clear this is
it
guys right it used to be more
you know the original version six
version looked more like manipulate
right with the white space
and the and the gray frame
around it
and so you're suggesting return a bit
more to that
look maybe
let me see if i can't generate a version
six uh
snapshot for you here okay but
but guys okay so look
this trimming yes that's the way it has
to be
similar to the trimming for you know a
summary box
it although it's the current styles
matching output suggestions
and it's more likely to be close in
proximity to that
yeah which is not necessarily good is
that your points you're making
no that it'd look odd to be completely
different
well fair enough if you stack them up i
don't think it looks that bad
now i i maybe we could change both of
them but to have them out of sync is
weird at least even if it's subtly out
of sync i think it's really weird all
right but so
does the output um does the does the
does this
oh you've got different font sizes i
don't have that
don't have well you're you're at once
because i'm magnified yeah okay
okay guys guys i i feel like this hasn't
been um
okay so i mean i don't think these
they can go darker than this because
this is really the main event this is
not like
oh you're expected to look at this giant
elided output no you're expected to see
that you need to take an action if you
want to see
you know making sense
yes
and i think some level of exotic color
is really kind of good for this
otherwise you think this is the whole
result
do you see what i'm saying i mean i
would be happy
to see for example if we were able to
have a dotted line around it that might
be a good way of indicating
that something kind of you know meta
about it yeah i like that
okay let's try that dotted or dashed
line around it
um
and that could have some degree of color
in it and i don't know what the
background color of the actual
cell should be and then this should go a
bit darker
and should match what we're doing in
blueness
or in well if in blueness you know this
is blue here
suggesting we don't go blue for those
actions
that make sense so so steven just for
reference i created uh
a snapshot of the original uh
v6 version and sent it to you
okay
yo i mean
this was really hitting you over ahead
with what was going on because we didn't
know whether people would understand it
turns out they did or at least i think
they did
i don't think we need to say that
look i think it's got to have a slightly
exotic color and it's got to have a
dotted line around it so can you
experiment with that please
okay yeah we can do that okay
so in terms of how it allies when it
goes narrower
um you know show more show less i would
put circles around the plus and minus
i can eyes i'm sure we have an icon for
iconized already
interestingly we don't we have uh
um icons for different sort of
things in their iconized form but we
don't have one for the act of iconizing
itself
that was something that came up in our
discussion
okay well let's make
let's make something that shows you sort
of packing a box
type thing
um feels like we must have done that
we'll we'll
we'll figure out the early stages of
that i bet we have some icons laying
around we didn't use
unpacking a box sounded familiar yeah
ethan on our live stream is commenting
on this
dynamic list view oh that's cool
yeah well that's very nice look the
whole
elided expressions thing i mean you've
got to realize that this
doesn't have the full notebook it can't
do this
actually no it can do this while it's
still in the kernel
right
right and and and you and one of the
things we're adding here
is the the embed inside so it will
survive a kernel restart if you wanted
to
right what does it look like after it's
been embedded it still has the very
large expression thing right
yes this is nice
this is very nice
that's cool i'm going to use this
right of course the difference is that
the you know
a list of things is a pretty simple case
where i know
i know i know i know i know the case of
the lighting bigger expressions is much
more complicated
yep what happens when you evaluate that
output
is it is it the full output or some
weird dynamic thing
i think it's a weird dynamic thing oh
okay just yeah
okay
yeah sandra is commenting he doesn't use
the show more show less buttons because
they don't work very well
show all and show compact is enough i
don't entirely agree i
i you know when the expression is too
big you're just going to blow everything
up if you say show all
and you are look the truth is the
correct way to do this is that you'll be
able to click on the illusion spots
and have them you know
i'm sorry i i can't help myself it you
know it's like i'm thinking of big bang
at the beginning of the universe have
them
start uh you know creating more
more matter so to speak sorry
i mean that's what they do in the
you know the stack trace on the messages
menu
okay well why can't they do that yeah
i mean that's what we should do with
these right so
uh like for example i wouldn't mind
seeing that one bigger
or that one bigger and being able to
choose
um so i'm not sure what what
brett is referring to with the stack
trace
um i mean there i think there are
right i don't know that we necessarily i
mean
which isn't to say we couldn't you know
rewrite this thing from scratch
but you know at least at the present
time i don't know that we
necessarily have a direct connection
between
you know that lobby that lozenge
and the underlying expression i
understand i understand i know i think
this this requires
more looking at i mean this is the
lighted expression project
it's it's a definite project we're not
solving it today
yep um is there approach
that data set took that would apply here
the paging i'm not sure how
the paging works there but it doesn't
hold it on
yeah well i agree that that i believe
that's correct
we should ask is jose here maybe that
knows
well i mean right well a lot as i speak
but right the data set
is fundamentally paging by rows and
columns which you have when you're a
data set
i see um i'm here
you're talking about the decide paging
yeah but but
right jeremy is i mean the problem is to
paginate this or even to line break this
jeremy
takes analyzing the whole expression
which could take a very long time
okay look i think this is a future
project we cannot solve that right now
okay so i think our project was was to
you know give it a fresh paint of code
with a few buttons based on what we were
doing
with summary boxes of code always a good
thing
the um okay but so if i press store
expression and no sorry sorry it just
registered
why you said that back to me right the
um the
um if it's been stored in the notebook
right what happens then it will say it
will still have all the stuff
in it right because it's still been
elided
do you get what i'm saying
hello i'm i i guess i missed something
okay look if i press storeful expression
notebook
it does not immediately display the
whole expression no
it it right so i'm asking what does it
look like after you've stored it in the
notebook because you still have to have
the stripe at the bottom here
right um so i think what it should say
is expression size blah blah blah stored
in notebook
that is that i think is
and certainly doable it may still right
it may not say this
start a notebook i mean you can you can
try the experiment right there i don't
think that
you know those are so large that they uh
you know will do anything untoward
um oh expression stored
ah okay so did do that that that
i didn't realize lou had done that um
question size expression
that's a bit subtle it is a bit subtle
as evidenced by the fact that i hadn't
realized that even though i had tested
that button
i think we should put paren stored in
notebook after it
okay i know it's a bit long and i you
know the solution
it just has to it has to go multi-decker
and drop the icons go multi decker
you know try and fit it all in
is it gonna be weird that like it sort
of
jumps when you click when you do the
store operation
that you're clicking on this thing on
the right and then it's
transforming into a thing farther to the
left
i don't think that's that weird
you're not going to click another one of
those buttons particularly
no i was just wondering whether it
should say you know should switch to
stored in notebook
sort of in that location in the
well okay fair enough it could
expression size blah blah
and then this could be black stored in
notebook
which is analogous to what happens up
here
wherever it is but no it doesn't say
stored in notebook because it has no
place to
put it because it is just stored
all right so let's try that try putting
stored notebook on the right there
maybe a check mark or notebook instead
to change that icon it would be nice
yeah
change the icon to check mark stored in
notebook expression stored in notebook
full expression stored in notebook
okay comment on the live stream from
uh two comments here one
sander commenting about the blue color
use mac system preferences general
accent color or highlight color
maybe i think we've got so many colors
going on they cannot all be the system
accent color
yeah i agree the
um
okay another comment from ethan you know
this is an interesting one
in a large image or graphic maybe add a
button to show it as a dynamic image or
dynamic graphic
that's an interesting idea
that's an interesting idea that in which
case they add this button
an image i understand but in which case
there was a first half to the sentence i
didn't oh okay when it's very big
give that option in other words allow it
to be a dynamically loaded asset
that will be very useful i mean i would
use that all the time
in writing these posts that i write
because i what i end up having to do
silly detail but i mean you know when i
write them i end up with these giant
images okay and i build this notebook
and it gets bigger and bigger and bigger
pretty soon it's 200 megabytes you know
bigger bigger bigger
because i need the original versions of
those pictures right but i don't need
them
i mean what i end up doing is i end up
storing other notebooks that have the
originals and then i end up doing silly
down sampling
usually by lazy lazy screen capturing in
the actual working notebook and then
somebody has to replace them later
do you see what i'm saying so
this idea would be and it's a good idea
is
is and it relates to what john fultz has
been wanting to do
with asset files this is a good idea
um
um i like that idea that idea i mean
that's a shoddy
etc idea but she should be showing what
has been done with these you know store
and notebook and so on
i really like that idea i'm really
silent
who's who's project managing no it makes
sense so this would come as part of the
the whole linked images project so so
when notebooks can
basically load a linked image that isn't
embedded exactly
exactly just kind of allow you to do
that right this is a this is a cheaper
way to do it
using dynamic image and so on yeah
on evan's project imagine managing if to
answer your question
yeah okay okay all right
okay let's look at the last item here
more formatting right so i
you know i i think why am i thinking
about
you know pigs digging for truffles here
right so this is root and differential
root this is driving me absolutely
bonkers
this this behavior um
which behavior the fact that i couldn't
figure out how to get out look at this
okay so i'm like i see it now
give it to me
you see what i'm saying i click it
nothing happens i'm like hello i can see
it but what do i do capture it
okay it is it there's no difference well
you
you convert it to input form it's
it's really not no well i guess you
could do that but
it's not on the root yeah yeah yeah i
understand
but i i think i you know given that this
will you know no matter
what we decide nothing is going to be
implemented in the next 23 hours
or i guess 25 hours
uh okay this is horrifying but to show
high details okay so here
we now have different freaking behavior
stephen this is why we have this
discussion
i know don't start out don't well then
don't don't start out by yelling about
things
okay okay why the lcc that's why we've
been doing lcc meetings for
however long all right are energy boxes
clickable like this
i don't believe so no
entity boxes have a different behavior
if you click them they go back to their
to that form oh but that's only because
you didn't click the check box
right i mean no that's interesting i
mean there's no noise
what's that does there's nothing to do
with entities that's the dynamic level
of control
not entities right so there's also an
interesting question whether the entity
should show you its input form in any
way
which for some reason i've been a lot
less interested in the input form of i
mean i just
i think the difference is and we have
seen this in feedback we got on vane
that sometimes you're interested in the
numeric value and sometimes you're
interested in the polynomial
and it is not always that you always
want the number and it's not always that
you always want to polynomial
right so of course you can always do
slash slash input form or
shift command i to convert it to input i
know but that
but this does not work in vain that's
not the possibility
why does this not work in wayne because
vein doesn't have
input it it's natural language level and
traditional form output level
it's a product that's surprised that you
can't do all mathematical coding
um right well then you should have a
show polynomial button which does this
such input form but i i mean first of
all
i mean you can turn it right you can
turn
turn this off if you really want to
there's a system option
but why can it not be much more summary
books
form like where we have both information
we get a degree of the polynomial
and we get the numerical value typically
i'm not interested in the
250s
i know but we need to know the degree of
the polynomial that's a good point but
that's not there is really frustrating
um okay uh well
well defender that that's the thing
actually you know what that's the thing
i'd be most missing
because i actually don't care about the
numerical value typically
you do but i do care about the degree of
the polynomial but i don't need all the
coefficients well
right well i mean but the i think well i
i disagree that
i disagree that your typical wayne user
wants
the polynomial right i think they want
the numerical value right no they want
to understand what's going on with the
polynomial
like the typical venue so we said uh
quad x goes to two and cubic close to
two
because they never want to see any such
object in the first place
okay fine but but if they happen to get
any of them
they would be less frightened by this
thing
than by a root object right of course
they would be less
but i mean you know we we got
i don't think they're more confused okay
listen
listen i every time i see this i'm like
drat that's not what i wanted okay okay
well okay so so well you approved it
so i mean i know so i made a mistake
okay
so i mean to my mind
i guess this point about what's the
order of the polynomial that's really
important
and the numerical value is probably less
important
right that's just the thing that
identifies right but right you you are
only worrying about the case where you
have
one of these right no no no when you
when you have
30 of them in a single output then you
don't want you want this to be small
i i completely agree okay but i'm happy
to see
you know something where it says 12th
order
order 12 and then this in in small
you know a small thing there that just
is essentially the id of the root
uh how about the other types of root
objects like we have
uh four of them right now so what what
should happen if
it's a root of a transcendental function
or a root of system of functions
but this one here for example oh that's
a differential
that's uh i know but but what does the
input what does this mean i don't know
what the heck this means
that that's telling you that it's a 12th
order
but it's not what it looks like i mean i
understand i i
i i guessed what this was okay but this
is the 12th
root this is the 12th derivative of y
right and what the heck does this have
to do with the 12th derivative of y
it's not the 12th derivative what i see
before me
is a you know
right but how are you going right how
are you going to abbreviate that any
useful
i don't know i don't know i mean i think
i mean i personally think order 12
since this has no id information if i
had
a second one of these right so i've got
this puppy and
i'm going to change oh gosh why is this
one that takes forever
okay i'm sure it's doing an incredibly
brilliant computation
what the heck is that
oh boy that's wrong
okay the output size limits are fired on
something which is absolutely tiny and
the output size limiter should not fire
on
yes that's a hard problem to solve okay
but it wasn't it wasn't firing before
was it
uh i i i stored it so
you uh well i see so you wouldn't be
distracted by that
raw in other words you hacked it okay
fine okay so that's a different problem
that's
that i would consider the bug
okay i have no idea whether this is i
don't know what this is going to do but
but
um uh my point is this could have
exactly the same yeah it has exactly the
same visual form
even though those are in fact different
differential root objects
okay right
and any any any reasonable
sized you know
right i know i know okay so listen
listen listen
what we do in cryptography right
um
my god what happened here that's a bug
that's a bug
somebody's got to go track that down got
it it's known and we're working on it
okay all right okay i mean if i do that
in
in the current version
right see that i don't know why there's
extra space there that's really weird
it's another bug but you see those
things there right
see those sure if i generate this again
they'll be different okay now what do
those mean who the heck knows
but the point is that you can see that
they're different
okay so i mean that's one possibility of
doing something a bit like that
essentially a bar code for these
differential roots
because it is rather confusing that you
have two apparently identical
differential roots that are actually
different
so what i'm saying i mean i think in
in the case um in this case
you know this just random colors but
here what i would do is some kind of
pattern of black and white things which
almost looks like
it's an absolutely minified version of
the actual output
it could even be a minified version of
the output
you see what i'm saying
did you get them actual output you mean
the full form
yeah i mean the full form of the thing
the actual differential root
right so in this case however i get it i
have no idea how to get it i'm sure i
can do it but maybe i can do it by copy
paste i don't know
yet okay
do command a nope command a doesn't work
well it did work it just selected
everything
i know but it did the wrong thing so
okay so let's say i take this
okay so now let's say i go
um
let me take that thing there
what i mean is
i don't know you know something like
that where that's been
i mean i don't know that's useful maybe
maybe there's a better way to do this
but that gives you some sense
even smaller than that little in a
little square gives you some sense that
there are lots of coefficients there
it could be a little complex plot of the
function
that would make them different if they
are different well yeah well if we
well if we were willing to pay the speed
price for running
a if you were willing to pay the price
uh
of running complex plot and b that's
assuming i
know over what domain to use yeah i
think that's hard i i personally think
that this is a better
right but but let me point out well for
like sparse array right
any right you know any right any two
three by three by three sparse arrays or
right will look identical
so right it's not like
i'm not sure why you're insisting that
differential routes
have to be i thought sparse array had
some in its icon
had some indication of the actual array
if it's one or two dimensions
okay well that's a good start i mean we
might imagine doing it for higher
dimensions some other time
it's clearly not critical i mean
widely reduced version would already be
if we would know we see already the
total order is 12
and all the coefficients in front of the
y primes
must be polynomials if we would know say
either the decree or the number of terms
of this polynomial
there could be still degenerate cases
but this would already dramatically
reduce it
right i mean to me this should be a
summary box with a little plus sign
i think oh yeah yeah well i mean if
you're if you're
wanting first of all uh i don't think
that's the best direction
but if you're going to argue for a
summary box you're going to have to
convince roger of that
because roger said from the start that
somebody he's not in this meeting but he
needs to be
i mean all right well then i'm kind of
going to insist that do we do something
about this because this is not useful
every time i get one of these all right
please
okay stephen you could you could you
know maybe look at some of the mock-ups
or we could actually have a discussion
instead of you just
complaining but i mean the mock-ups
don't address this issue
of showing the mock-ups deal with the
coloration of the out
of this which is fine and a good start
right
sure um
i do think this lighter stack trace is
better
and this is certainly better but i don't
think it solves the main problem
okay the main problem is to display
particularly for the algebraic number
case
the degree of the polynomial
what should happen with other root
objects like the ones that are not
polynomial or
not what can you say about them
well there is a transcendental functions
other than that
it doesn't have a degree or anything i
can print the function or not
i think it should just have a little
plus size i think it should say should
indicate that it's transcendental
it should say 12th order or it should
say transcendental
and then it should have a little plus
sign
and if we had to lose if we had to make
this smaller
i'd be okay with that even just two
digits if necessary but three is nice
i would make that number smaller and
say you know twelfth order
and gray down that number because that
number is really not that important
that number is just a hash code
effectively
well it's a thing that i find that
number incredibly useful
right if i if i solve and then i get
you know a bunch of these things and i
have some sense of what order numbers
i'm looking at
okay which i don't get from the input
form of the polynomial
fine i agree that's a good argument yeah
the number is important
okay fine but the number and the degree
are both important
and a plus sign to just see more
properties seems important to me
which is exactly what we've done for the
differential root case and i just think
we should do it for the other cases as
well
sure and i mean there's maybe some
version where there
there's more than two states right so
um i mean i haven't quite figured out
how how
how to do that but what do you mean more
than two states
right open and close right there could
be
is this another thing for now this is
this is just
you've already picked the thing it just
hasn't been implemented so
i believe you picked version three
is that right yes i think i did
so it was it was just there for for
reference as
another you know calculus algebra thing
that got
a a fresh coat of paint
recently or i guess will
uh because i only got the specs you know
the detailed spec i need to
to actually implement it and not just a
pretty picture this week so
it's not in the build yet but you know
making this change is pretty easy
okay sounds good
okay okay well so i mean again again
eventually what we need is a pull down
here that's a standard summary box like
pull down
that has
you know and so long as there's some
indication you can click doesn't need to
be a plus necessarily
some indication you can click
even just a hover effect that suggests
you can click on this
okay which is what you've done for
differential route anyway
well well i i i did that i i did that
more recently
and okay but it was
and it's on average much bigger so and
it has more structure
right i understand that i understand
that so what i'm saying is that
there should be a hover effect for all
of them and you know once there's a
hover effect you know you can click
we should try to display the degree
and once you've clicked it should be
like a standard summary box like thing
that could have additional openers and
so on
i'm not sure i understand what you mean
by once you've clicked it's a summary
box like thing
okay once you click on this object okay
which right now is a nut to click array
yep right once you click that i'm saying
it should do the exact same
kind of thing that this does except this
should be differently formatted
okay that's right yeah i'm just not
making the connection to summary boxes
but
i guess you're just saying it should
provide you with more info in a useful
way
like that does yes which i agree with
right including give me the number which
sandra is commenting on a live stream
people don't understand
you know that that gives the number and
the
and the magic of the fact that i could
say this
and get that number
all right okay anything else we should
cover right now
don't think so okay good work thanks to
everybody here thanks to folks on the
live stream